ever since wheeler differentiation at
the beginning of the year okay some of
you I heard I got a little suspicious of
these two formulas okay now we learnt
these when did you learn these formulas
like in your seven right there's gotta
be yeah before what you then does anyone
run off someone's advice when you were
very young
you learnt these okay and you could use
them in a lot to use okay but when you
learn differentiation ready when you let
that process I wanted you to for about
these and thought there's something
sauce going on here okay is it a
coincidence that this is true or is
there actually something going on okay
now the problem with thinking about this
for about differentiation point of view
right now is that looking at this and
trying to work out is it a coincidence
or is it not you can't get very far just
thinking about what we know about what
differentiation means and what we know
about what derivatives me okay
because you like differentiation gives
you what gives your gradient right so
you're like gradient of an area like
that today it doesn't come right um
because it doesn't yeah it doesn't
really make sense because how does an
area which is that which is the number
two value how does it kind of great
right now the reason why you couldn't
make much sense of it is because the key
you were missing was integration okay so
now we can actually fill it in this
thing which you learn from whatever ten
years old six years old okay it took
until you maybe ten years eight years
whatever so you could learn this thing
actually
why is it the case now to make it as
clear as I possibly can you need to do a
little imagining with me okay it's not
quite storage but anyway take your
circle and what I want you to imagine is
if we try to work out the area of this
thing okay
the problem is you can't cut it up into
like rectangles and triangles or other
kinds of shapes because you always gonna
have leftovers right you only think you
can really divide this up into that we
know about and which we can actually
calculate is are the seconds okay so let
me take your circle and I want you to
imagine filling this circle up with a
series of concentric circles like this
so I actually want you to do all this on
okay
the reason what I'm saying imagine is
because you can't actually now what I've
got is an infinite number of
infinitesimally small areas right this
is starting to rebound now here's the
important thing right it's infinite
number of infinitesimally small
you know because each individual circle
that I doesn't really have an area you
know really because it's right but if
you want to have an area
what would the area of each individual
thing be the answer is well it's a whole
bunch of Chicot Frances isn't it like
each one is a circumference but its
owner and I have an infinite bunch of
okay so keep your imagination fair I
actually used to do this with beads but
it weren't quite the wimpy thing enough
on a boy why don't you do is take take
one of those circumference is actually
and imagine if it was like a it was a
stream okay I want you to cut the string
let's make one cut and then and then
pick it up and now what you've got is
it's hanging paint down so it's just a
straight line okay
now you can do this cut end and
straighten thing for every single
of these concentric circles okay and if
your voidable up next to each other what
do you get okay well this circled by in
the very center is just the point okay
that's the smallest circle that I've got
the biggest circle but I've got will be
the whole thing right now how long is
the whole thing how long is that biggest
circumference well if I call it if I
call the Bradys ah right
did it click if I call the radius R then
this longest circumference should be
okay now every time I go from here to
here the circles the circumference is
I'm just gonna get something is okay now
just 19 bells what I'm trying to do is
take this big area which I've now
chopped up into a whole bunch of little
slices okay and okay what does each one
add up to and then I've got my total
okay now admittedly I I don't need
integration to work out the area of this
new shape that day okay because it's a
triangle right I've already looked at
its height what's the base it's it's
this distance here is exactly the same
as distance here you see that it's all
I've done is just rearranged a little
bit right so it's ah and as you know
triangle is base times height which is
basis so that's comforting because it's
what we knew already okay
but I am interested in developing this a
little more right and you'll see why
later but you know of course if we use a
trailer but let's be a little more
sophisticated this process and adding up
an infinite number infinitesimally thin
things right we've been looking at this
right this is what integration is all
about so how would you bring your
understanding of integration to this
problem in petite
since we try to work out an area
what definite integral would you fool
okay I need a function here right so
instead of like what way did this come
from what function b this.b a product
well some kind of straight line right
goes through the origin
okay and if I go forward I give this I
should go up to PI R you know you told
me what's the equation of this line
right over 1 2 pi so that's just the
gradient yeah possibly the origin so
that's why I got plus B for a while is
it ok sure if this is what I want right
and now this is the area I'm I've done
the definite integral that you would
form looks like this where am i upper
and lower balance there from zero to R
what's the function that I'm integrating
it's okay well let's just take that part
out don't leave the tricks I think you
can see why not punches the closest to X
well what's the primitive of 2x this is
pi it's the knot plus C because it's
definite right and so what I've got here
is I made to allow that evaluated 0 so
this is sir
so can you see apart from triangles and
stuff right this is this is not random
this comes from integration right now
here's what's really cool okay that was
sort of like maybe you saw that coming
okay but maybe just backtracking a
little bit right
this process here it didn't really
require us to cut everything out and
rearrange it like a triangle okay
because integration will always work
whenever you're adding up an infinite
number of infinitely small things
whatever they are they don't have to be
in straight lines you just go back to
you know this thing and just imagine
well what's the circumference of each
one it's still gonna behave like this
okay now the important thing I wanna get
across to you is that just like saying
trigonometry started trying right but
you can apply to much more than
triangles just waiting to do simple
harmonic motion next year okay in the
same way integration starts with an area
okay but you can use it for much more
than areas example circles circumference
and area aren't the only famous circle
formulas that you learn for a very young
age right you also learn if you take
another circle but a sphere okay its
surface area is 4 PI R squared
ok now that can be calculated by
measurement just like circumference you
calculated by measuring okay well how do
you read from something like that to a
volume well just like how I divide it up
right the area into a bunch of
circumference is okay so at the volume
of a sphere right I'm gonna take that
volume and cut it up into an infinite
number of infinitesimally thin surface
areas does that make sense so they're
kind of like shells if you like like
I've got Bush kadhal or an onion or
something like that okay so now stay
with me what am I gonna do again the
smallest
she'll well there's smaller surface area
that I've gone right it's gonna have a
radius of zero and the biggest one will
have a radius of okay now every
individual surface area follows this
kind of rule right so let's check that
in and don't worry that they won't say
that it's just gonna go back in okay now
for constant pi plus it R squared
what's the primitive of a square
yeah so of course this zero is just
gonna it's gonna disappear and put that
three out the front where we usually put
it and there is your volume formula okay
now every you seven asks for thirds
where's for thirds come from there's
totally senseless like why would a
number like that creep into a nice you
know newborn formula the circle doesn't
have reardon fractions in it well the
answer is where did the third come from
it came from it came from the primitive
function right so now you know why you
seven teachers never explain to you
where the Four Thirds careful because
they'd be like well there's this thing
called a primitive function and you have
to increase the power of it and divide
by the and so you see why they explain